hello and welcome to this video playing
attack GM that's Julian Hodgson he
usually goes for his Trump so you might
have a trump I really feel he plays
better than his rating suggests him I
mean to 350 years I mean I usually
reside like on to 450 so I currently him
I'm in a slump I don't know yeah techno
in place yeah he s been higher 2600 come
on so let's see what is up to yeah we
kind of expected that so let's see this
one year and then he sick said that's my
recommendation here f3 Bishop t6 I think
black is fine in this position it's just
extremely unconventional which makes it
difficult because he is an extremely
good player in a in in those
unconventional situations okay let's do
it i recently had this inner in a game
in a blitz game and i remember that i
did not play it well I think I played
some e five year maybe it was against
him I'm I really don't remember this all
that clearly
five is interesting for him to come
maybe in time to play don't quite
remember the thing is I have a hard time
to develop he I cannot really take maybe
Bishop to be seven as an idea but after
a five I don't know where I'm putting
this piece okay not so happy about this
the light on c7 doesn't look like a
fantastic piece but maybe this is
putting enough pressure here on d5 i
also have night c4 as an interesting
move whoa I thought this is good for me
isn't that beautiful black what am i
overlooking here I queen bee three I
take with the pawn d 695 looks awful Wow
hmm interesting 93 he will take here but
on those nights add those nights
dangerous they certainly are I can take
here and take on g2 I just wonder which
one this one probably I can take both
plants and I have pawn to c4 then then
Queen you follow so let's just grab the
grab stuff I can take a form and we'll
take our form yeah back here and then f6
next move will be f6 basically no matter
what and five is the only alternative
worth checking because i get f 4 at 3h
for immediately this actually looks
strong what we need for immediately
maybe this is an alternative if he goes
to g2f for that's 94 that actually isn't
that great that isn't isn't so great
okay five though it is also pretty good
but doesn't feel decisive I don't have a
decisive attack here that's somewhat
surprising actually check check 95 or
something and then f45 LF for I am I
blundering something here I don't know
f4f 494 okay move first think later f3r
up to five this this looks like I'm
kidding myself so let's not do that okay
I'm certain I probably should move this
first I cannot move this I'm not doing
this so well here right that was a very
winning position and this is probably
winning but still some work and I'm down
to one minute
I mean I had a situation about them I
was hot material and end attacking and T
I'm not attacking don't know where g6
helps but I want to prepare to get five
him did that hi morning ca3 happening
okay five here that looks like a good
idea prob just that shaggy coming up but
now at least I can move the f porn so
f3r up to 7 27 I don't think I don't
know I don't buy that he just takes it
isn't that winning chat then some Queen
III with h3 something doesn't win no
Queen f4 maybe for Queenie for that also
doesn't run steep bonus running now now
it's for this stuff unbelievable ah
crazy I did really spoil this position
fantastic d70 can probably just play d7
crazy I'm just crazy yeah I have no
moving between 21 King v2 or whatever it
loses
ah Mensch this is so idiotic black eyes
I'm that's really that's really that
that sucks I mean that sucks I mean how
bad can you play really er I mean you
just weakened every square possible and
invited me just to win there and I don't
that you don't do it happen that said so
Justin Justin Lydia blunders two full
points I don't get this to work
unbelievable now I can win even more
material of course but yeah I was
thinking this is some more a good idea
okay it probably takes a while until it
is not winning but if the trend is not
so great here you know okay I probably
only spoil it somewhere here when i move
the f porn a queen h3 is checkmate okay
f2m I just have to cover this I'm just a
mindless idiot sometimes I have a minute
on the clock I don't know sometimes i'm
just very active a player here is Queen
III at least some kind of draw it okay
bye now I'm I kind of understand that
I'm them that I'm not not finding
anything anymore they're here this is
not exactly difficult but I don't like
this to happen in the first place this
this was just just so easy before
teenage 3 also was pretty easy but hi
Jim Queen f 54 forward how is this a
draw I because this no is not
threatening to to actually promote so
this is keep this is holding your ok
difficult and yeah even this is still at
all I knew that I have no move after
this but yeah by now I wasn't clearly
thinking I was just so frustrated that
is that this game wasn't over already
maybe I should have just done this and
open open everything now can't attorney
it doesn't matter it's it's it's all
just a question what completely winning
position do you want what is what makes
it so easy that you know I cannot spoil
it but that's probably a hot k this
isn't totally terrible but it should
have been ordered by that by that point
oh ok thanks for watching